the shock resignation of Nicholas
stargen just over two weeks ago dealt a
huge blow to the Scottish independence
movement so who should be the one to
pick up the pieces and lead the SMP all
three contenders have seen their
campaigns thrown into controversy at
some point so much so that the former
leader and fast Minister Alex salmond
has compared the contest to the Titanic
so does he think the eventual winner is
doomed to fail and what would that mean
for the dream he strived towards for
decades Alex Sam thanks so much for
joining us on the show today at such an
important time in Scottish politics and
I I want to start off with Nicholas
sturgeon's surprise resignation as SMP
leader and also first Minister last
month for many years you were the
closest of allies and together you built
this formidable electoral machine in the
SMP now's your chance to pay tribute to
her
well I mean as I've said I mean Nicholas
uh both as an election winner and as a
communicator is one of the most
formidable politicians that has been
over there over the last while and both
of these attributes were amply
demonstrated through her career and what
will her Legacy be that's more difficult
to be because I mean obviously an SMP
politician or a Scottish independence
politician uh you know you have to look
for the Legacy as how close you advance
towards that goal the and there and I
think Nicholas
you'd have to say that you know Scotland
is not any closer to Independence than
it was in 2014 certainly the dial hasn't
shifted greatly elections have been won
in the interim but the the deal and
Independence hasn't been shifted now
that's a of course a hard criteria to to
judge politics and say you know it's
bigger because most politics I'm a UK
politician would largely be judged by
how many elections to do it but I think
somebody just believes in Scottish
independence as I do unequate those they
would want to be judged by how close you
advance towards that that goal or that
dream so you you clearly didn't agree on
her her strategy but her leaving
um Scottish politics in this way at this
in terms of the leadership at least I
mean it's the end of an era isn't it of
of you and and then ha and I know that
you didn't really like each other by the
end but is there any sadness do you look
at back in sadness now about how the
relationship ended well well of course
but I mean I mean you know that note
that that's something between Nicola and
myself but the important point for you
know the other five and a half million
Scots and particularly the supporters of
Independence is a a combination which
was taken Scotland looked like an
exitable march to Independence there's
no very much up in the up in the air
just two more things on this
um do you think that Nicholas Sergeant
exiting in the way she's exit with no
obvious successor has let the cause down
she's made things extremely difficult
for her successors in the sense that
they've been plunged that they depend
now they may swim you know not everybody
gets flung in the deep end sinks and
they're talented individuals but they've
got a very short period of time I'd like
to talk to you about the candles before
I do Peter morale SMP chief executive
given what you've just said do you think
he should stay in post well no I don't
but I mean I'm not really the personal
task it's the the candidates the next
leader because of the way in which this
has been handled well Peter obviously
you know I didn't think Peter should
stay in post back in 2014 I think it's
one of the reasons why you know Peter is
uh hasn't held me in any regards a sense
because I didn't think it was an
appropriate combination to have the the
leader of a party and the country or
simultaneously and I mean as well at
least one of the candidates on perhaps
two of them have said in this contest it
wouldn't be be it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be decided as reasonable in any
business organization and there's
questions about someone now there's
particular question marks no so I don't
think so but you know look that's not
really for me and that's you know that's
for the SMP and the SMP candidate let's
move on to the leadership let's talk
about Kate she had a Kate Forbes had a
tough start over those remarks around
gay marriage you're a Christian does it
concern you that her ideas about gay
marriage and sex outside marriage seem
to have essentially disqualified her
from the chance of becoming Legion and
fast Minister oh I I don't think she's
disqualified and but she's had a rough
start I don't think well let's continue
the Stephen position is irredeemable but
and and you know I think
it would be of great concern not just to
me but if people's religious convictions
or lack of convictions uh disqualified
them from a leadership uh position in a
political party on the other hand the
Kate has I've seen from a more recent
pronouncements it has got to explain
better the very reasonable distinction
you make between a private faith and
public policy and now that that
distinction has been made hopefully
people are more comfortable about it you
know you know well one of the difference
I introduced equal marriage and we did
it before any other country in these
islands and when we did it back in 2011
2012 it was quite controversial I want
to ask you about Hamza Yousaf uh and
he's now the favorite when he took
advantage of forbes's troubles and
criticized her position on gay marriage
now as he was saying you you were the
first Minister legislating for same-sex
marriage back in 2014 when Mr Youssef
was in your cabinet he voted for equal
marriage initially but he later missed a
crucial vote on that legislation did he
or anyone on his behalf ever get in
touch with you as first Minister back in
2014 to discuss that final vote Yes
can you expand on that well I mean I've
been very reluctant to get involved with
this because you know it's an internal
SMP leadership battle and you know I
really don't have an organist race you
know and and anything I see you know
people say oh he's only saying that
because he's leading a developer you
know but you were the fast minister at
the time so you all know yes so what
happened well I mean my memory is that I
was contacted 10 days or so before the
before the vote when the vote was known
and told that Hamza was arranging a
ministerial appointment I've discussed
it with people who are with me at the
time so I know it's what their memory is
the same as mine but what was the reason
that was given to to have to skip the
vote well and I didn't
discuss the the thinking great landfill
was the Assumption was there was
pressure
there's a lot of religions
religions were were canvassing and
opting it's no secret though there was
uh there was that but it was a free vote
and people could do it like I
administers
who were against a equal marriage and
who voted against equal marriage and
they continued as Minister sorry you you
but you're saying that there was
pressure Mr Yousaf was on on depression
that was communication lots lots of
people directly all through a third
party that was communicated but lots of
pressure from the Muslim Community
no doubt other communities as well I
mean look that aspect of it to me is
irrelevant it was a conscious vote a
free vote Hamza had made his General
views on the issue perfectly clear and
the first reading quote and it was
totally uncontroversial it was a
conscious vote a conscience vote but can
I just this is what he's I'm just going
to play because this is what his
explanation was if I make and we this is
from school I've told you what that
business was you asked me quite rightly
earlier this week but what was that
business it was a Scott who was on death
row for blasphemy in Pakistan that we
were desperately trying to get released
a series of meetings needed with
Pakistani government and Pakistan no
other day in your diary no other point
in your diary you couldn't have
rearranged that to make such a historic
vote in the Scottish Parliament again I
made the historic vote in stage one
where are you under pressure though by
religious groups at that point let's
just clear that up what representations
were made to you from religious groups
because the timing from your opponent's
point of view looks very suspect look a
couple of things first of all I think
every single member of the Scottish
Parliament was lobbied by not just Faith
groups there was a number of other
groups who opposed equal marriage at the
time I was no different but I also speak
to my community in the Muslim Community
in particular I speak to them very often
about the positions that I take some
will agree some will disagree but to
think that the Muslim Community has one
homogenous view I think would be
incorrect
so I just want to clarify this because
it matters about the leadership contest
I think did did he miss the vote because
of
religious pressure and he didn't want to
stop
a meeting
you asked me you no no you asked me what
my memory was was I contacted to say
that Hamza had arranged a governmental
meeting uh on the day of the vote and
that was sometime before the vote the
answer is yes I remember that
but you know there's memory you know may
be different from my let's put it that
way
what do you mean well you know he he
seems to he seems to have a different
recollection from what I do or what Alec
Neil has so be it so just to be clear
your recollection was that it was a
conscience vote
um but that vote was missed because of
religious pressure that it was a vote
that Mr Youssef perhaps wanted to avoid
well that's your recollection well
that's my recollection Okay the reason
I'm asking you is because
Mr Youssef has used Kate Forbes position
on gay marriage to criticize her yeah
and then there's a point about whether
or not he for religious reasons I always
tried to dodge that vote and that
matters
my observation is he did that once with
it and he shouldn't have done that in my
view but uh you know most of the the
stuff that's been aimed at Kate was you
know the various I don't know what you
call them accolades or whoever it was
from behind the scenes and incidentally
for all the candidates all three
candidates it would be a tremendous idea
and this is the last piece of advice I'm
going to give to this I'll be leadership
election call off that sort of stuff it
doesn't look good and in terms of
um
you and the s p and your future do you
rule out ever joining or rejoining is
that is that chapter in your
Independence Journey now closed
rejoining the SMP would you do you
completely rule it out well I mean it's
unwise to ever rule anything out in
politics but the my focus on I believe
I've been if they've heard the penis all
my life uh and uh for the vast majority
of that are pursued it through the
through the SMP I hold the s p an
enormous affection but you know I lead a
political party Aleppo which I think is
a a substantial role to play have you
had any contact with Australian since
Nicholas sturgeon's departure I mean
I've uh I mean I'm not going to talk
about the conversations I've had but if
you let's talk about three candidates
I've been as I've already explained to
you for reasons I know Hamza well
because he used to work for me about
nothing else and uh you know I've I know
the the two women less well uh well a
little bit better into the booth but I'm
not going to tell you when and I wish
all three candidates well in the context
let me just ask you about the couple
more things the coronation Stone the
stone of Destiny or coronation Stone was
returned to Scotland in 1996 and now
it's needed to go back to England for
King Charles's coronation but you don't
think that it should be allowed to go do
you well it's not my most serious policy
that I'm putting forward at Beth but you
know in a context where the legitimate
desire of people in Scotland to at least
have a referendum on self-determination
has been denied by the Westminster
government I don't really see why any
Scottish government should just
immediately say it will give you back
the property which you stole 700 years
ago so would you watch whoever wins this
contest whoever becomes first minister
to refuse to allow that stone to go back
I probably would actually but they're
the better but the product so probably a
whip it away before the contest is
finalized that's the sort of Bin that
was the kind of underhand trick Stone in
the first place
Alex and I've got one more question for
you Independence once seemed within
touching distance you managed to secure
that Independence referendum at the
moment it looks like it's a more distant
dream do you still think it will come in
your lifetime yes it will and as someone
said the dream shall never die
okay Alex Simon thank you so much for
your time okay pleasure thank you
after my interview we asked for a
response from Hamza Yusuf to those
claims made by Alex summoned about why
he missed a crucial vote on same-sex
marriage he had a different version of
events to the former fast Minister my
recollection is very different to Alex
ammon's recollection Alex Ammon there's
also I think by any objective measure
um he has he has of course backed other
candidates in this race if he has every
right to do that Minister for
parliamentary business who would have
been in charge four slips for any
Minister has made it very clear Joe
Fitzpatrick that I was not one of those
who raised concerns around the equal
management I've given you a full account
corner of the reasons why I had to miss
that vote if it had taken place if I had
been there I would have voted for it the
vote took place today is Alex salmond
not telling the truth to you then well
as I said my recollection is definitely